yo what's up harry hey i'm good man how
are you i'm doing well this is so
surreal like i've been watching all your
content for the past so many months oh
man well well thank you so much dude
this is surreal for us to have uh you
know such a high level uh chess player
here on the stream man thanks for making
the time so what's going on what's
happening how's everything in in your
world so i'm i'm at a friend's place oh
that's right that's right i'm traveling
and my friends i should call him and
levy come in here
um my friend is also a chess youtuber
you may know the name uh gotham chess
yes
[Music]
right on cue what's up what's up dude
i'm a big fan uh you're a big
inspiration you know because i've got a
blossoming music career now combining
chess and music so is that right
well no not not really but i didn't i
did make a wrap for uh one million
subscribers on youtube so uh oh dude yes
i have to watch that i have to watch
that no you don't as a matter of fact
you probably don't
don't it's a pretty good bit don't make
it unlisted don't make it unlisted i
know that's what you're trying to do so
i'm gonna provide freestyle commentary
or attempt to while you guys play this
rapid fast uh bullet chess and then did
you have some words you want to throw me
or are we saving that for the next beat
i think we're saving that for next beats
this game should take no more than two
to three minutes so it's gonna be pretty
quick all right here we go i'm gonna
drop my beat i'm ready let's do this all
right
uh
yeah yeah yeah yeah pawn goes out out
comes the night putting up the fight and
moves the bishop hey yo we never bout to
give up on the pawn back and forth
claiming seconds at a time night comes
out at the angle just to wreck your mind
pawn captured pawn toppled over it gets
picked back again hmac i'm tapping into
rap for them bishop moving closer i will
expose you they chose to keep it in
effect 59 seconds hold up what the heck
gained another second now it's claimed
hey yo i'm spitting in 3d while watching
this bullet chest game bullet to the
brain how it feels we gon keep it real
back and forth i'm a rapping scorch
staying on the course night slides in
feeling like i'm watching fast forward
man i better be picking it up and
kicking some more words so i can keep
pace and goes to pawn for pawn they make
the exchange i'm saying spitting the
flames i know i'm ready to make all the
gains uh bishop be getting much closer
you know where exposure is backing the
way now i'll be rapping for days uh
harry mackinnon what can i say oh no
damn they knocked the king down that
would have been a give up situation imma
live up to the sickest type creations
queen swooping yeah y'all know we be
making all the mean movements the
situation is improving check the time
and i'm in perfect alignment when
rhyming hit hands to the temple this
situation getting mental could be a
problem could be the quick finish
situation might get diminished i'm like
pop i offered the spinach down to 47
seconds versus 55 46 they gained another
second it gets live it's hardly gone
down from a minute hey yo this game
might never finish who's gonna win it
y'all know we all up in it no one is
timid the level of chess that's on my
screen to be here with these
international mass is a dream hey yo
might be grand masters by the time i'm
done with these bars y'all know we
having fun thus far making maneuvers 46
seconds down to 39 got it back to 40 and
perfect time my words are lined 44 43
counting down i make you nervous i'm
just living out my purpose if you lose
you won't deserve this hey yo they going
head-to-head i see the neurons firing
till the moment they expiring never
retiring hey yo i'm just coming with the
rap sound brief pause in the game to
mention the piano keys in the background
with the chords and the classical
movement harry mack i'm doing this the
truest every time i rhyme i combine it
with music yeah y'all know when i spit
my rhymes i shine like ultraviolet hey
yo please don't make your chest rap
private we celebrating queen be moving
we be swooping what we doing i be
watching 3d motion use caution the
knight takes the pawn on the side i go
beyond you with the strongest high vibe
swooping in the big maneuver
yelling out we gotta vocalize these are
the dopest guys your brain is what i go
inside we are supposed to rise you're
getting posterized yeah we gon put you
all up on the wall mecca's never gonna
fall oh my god peace is getting taken
hey yo this situation is hotter than
satan wait is that peace upside down i'm
about to ride round hell no harry mack i
got the funnest vibe yo now his hat is
like the green felt on the underside hey
yo i'm making maneuvers if you switched
it back to green felt on the board then
the movement would be smoother 24 to 23
now the pound gets thrown bullet chest
man y'all got me fully up in my zone
let's go
[Music]
fire
now that was that was amazing shout out
to the both of y'all thank you so much
for for coming on here and and doing
that man what a what a display of of of
skills so fun to watch
and uh definitely fun to rap about and i
think we have another i definitely have
another beat cute up here um if i think
you you guys were going to throw me some
words for the next freestyle is that
right yeah definitely um we have a list
of four if that's okay yes we have never
resign
say it again
never resign never resign
yes correct which is what you did i
believe against mr beast so uh it's a
key strategy
yeah we have arch nemesis arch nemesis
yep which is basically like we're kind
of each other's arch nemesis but we're
also friends right
and we have attack and defense attack
and defense yep and then the final one
it's a bit more conceptual but it's pov
of a chess piece
pov of a chess piece that is dope that
is dope that's amazing yeah against mr
beast i was i was like yo
am i supposed to resign right now like
chess.com because i thought it was over
for me and then somehow we got the uh we
we squeezed out the old uh stalemate
situation there it ended up being a draw
that was amazing
um
this is amazing i love these words let's
make it happen i got a beat are you all
ready
let's do it let's do
it uh
yeah
come on yeah come on uh eric rosen in
the house uh got some chats in the house
come on hey y'all know what we about
yeah uh uh yeah yeah check it listen uh
turn me up turn me up turn me up yeah i
blow your mind with the cleverest rhymes
no matter what's going down yo never
resign hmac when i rhyme you know i make
you feel great you never know you might
pull off the stalemate yeah y'all know
i'm forever gonna flow with these freeze
man i thought that it was over for me
how could i win in my brain it's a
mystery i almost resigned and gave the
dub to mr beast yeah hey yo but in the
end i had the vision and i recognized
like his videos he's given he gave me
the draw hey yo we made it happen and
while i was playing chess i was straight
rapping i'm snapping and y'all know i
got em overdosing you gotta never resign
we gon keep this thing in motion and to
my title in this game the mac is about
to live up you'll never see me resign
you'll never see me give up back up on
it y'all know that they remember this
rosen and gotham we got the arch nemesis
combination yo y'all know i bring the
remedies bring the energy yo these news
is like enemies well they like frenemies
cause they got love yeah it's every mack
i'm truly bout to rise above uh and
y'all know that i'm infinite when i rock
they just shot bullets back and forth
one minute on the clock gaining a second
remaining through the opening there's a
long list of rappers that i'm dope
within yeah i'm the illest one off the
top i'm who they mentioned to be real it
was hard to follow this in three
dimensions yeah one minute on the clock
y'all left me floored after this i'm
getting off the internet buying a board
let's do it it's mag man i'm moving off
the digital so i can play a pivotal game
up in the physical
and every mac y'all know i'm saying what
i meant hey yo we focus on the attack
and the defense you see from my games
that there was a challenge i was always
too defensive i'm still trying to find
that balance yeah and y'all know i'm
nice when i release this i'm getting on
the offense and straight snatching your
pieces i'm doing what i'm feeling i'm
the freestyle fiend i wish i could enter
the pov of the queen but nah that's too
predictable so i won't give up i'm about
to enter to the pov of the bishop yeah
and y'all know with my flow they can't
tangle see i'm the bishop i prefer long
angles yeah y'all know that i'm a boss
oh lord i look for the angular move
straight across the board yeah and to
watch where i'm going ain't easy cause
if you're not paying attention you won't
see me i cleanly swiping from the side
i'm moving three squares diagonally yo
it's a vibe i wish i could hop around
like some of the others but see in my
game i only get one color yeah and
sometimes i feel it's not fair wishing i
could change colors hop to a different
square but that's why there's two of me
on opposite sides yeah every time i move
diagonal it's a vibe yeah check it when
i do it man i'm fly like a sparrow i'm
the bishop so i'm never staying on the
straight and narrow uh and y'all know if
i said it then i meant to see my path up
in this game of chess y'all know i gotta
bend it i see the boy differently from
corner to corner the illest performer i
tried to warn ya i'm here to scorn ya
see it through my eyes i help you
realize i'm here with some of the
greatest world-renowned chess guys let's
go
hey
thank you thank you thank you